morning what are we doing today today's
a day of adventure they want the
official day one all right Sheriff
official day one to Japan woke up really
early like at 5:00 a.m. and I was up
apparently part was creeping around
eating all the snacks that you got for
free last night yeah he ate mine but uh
Brannan Jarrah Brandon Sakai today
alright cuz he was here in April so II
that's a that's enough credentials for
us to honor him to be our tour guide is
a small trash can
does it look cooler here or does America
look cooler it looks cooler all right we
got a creamy latte start off the morning
we're all trying to figure out how to
use this vending machine so guess we've
been here about 15 minutes I think an
embarrassment this coffee here it came
out warm and it's a can it's warm
diapers
oh I can smell it so I was really good
Oh mom I'm gonna get one too all right
eeny if you have it you take this one I
want a harder one oh man okay fine it's
okay
that will seem to try it mmm oh that's
good you look really cute with your hood
on and your gold jacket on and a Apple
drink in your hand
after some more walk and we decided to
stop at a where we're thin 11 anymore
we're at Family Mart
and we might get some fried food
I think I'm again fried chicken because
Gina said it's bomb here okay this may
go clustered in one Japanese can I have
a bite
Sandra grab one of these rice demahjay
geese I don't know what these things are
called five six seven eight nine Thank
You Domo let's see what this fried
chicken here is all about Gina
recommended it you want a bite yeah
cover it
what am i you wanna buy yeah yah whoa
big bite tastes like KFC it's a cup free
right uh-huh
KFC original recipe that you like fried
chicken I think I think I've never seen
you eat so much chicken you're actually
eating it down to the bone that is a
first
no American Frankie now you want
American fried chicken
you don't usually like eating a lot of
food but now I know what food to get you
if I need to beat you and to make sure
you for sure he is fried chicken
just a good thing about a bringing Isaac
along aside from having Isaac experience
everything is we get to impact every
other JK members life by having them
practice being a parent
so I'm brandy loved holding his hand
earlier gmail is holding everybody adopt
Isaac so ready for babies
I was inpatient I crossed your boy
crossing first the Shibuya crossing is
famous because it's a 1 2 3 4 5 5 5 way
intersection of some pretty big streets
and just like the Time Square of Tokyo
essentially it's crazy hot we're
contemplating eating at this spot it's
so pegs not even open yet all these
people are waiting they all have to take
this we don't we just arrived but it's
sushi and it looks pretty bomb alright
so we finished waiting we waited about
how long do we wait like an hour I say
about an hour
wait about our family in the restaurant
and we're trying to figure out where
we're going to eat we're going to order
two of these ones these are like that's
like the ultimate that you could order
here stupid crap and that cost two
thousand eight hundred yen and they're
where you're going to hear we hear that
tuna is also the go to fish in Japan
we're gonna order a player just tuna
sorted sushi here two thousand eight
hundred as well and then it's going to
order Zuzu this one has smaller play for
herself six nine hundred and then we're
gonna go crazy and go for some America
rule as well 1,050 ready what are you
gonna get Isaac 19 - it was your ready
gotcha and we did the math and that's
gonna be eleven thousand five hundred
fifty one dollars four hundred yen
father do decimals in so we move two
Devils over this will essentially cause
us a hundred and fifteen dollars and
fifty cents I think she's pretty
affordable here how much is it it's
gonna be about a hundred fifteen
I'm concerning how much food we're
getting and the quality quality is
probably the best egg custard thingy
majiggy I've ever had it's like if brick
it's like tofu
yeah it's digging it I know
Isaac is very picky but look at him I'm
so proud of him right now is the most
amazingly impatient yet
crab innards crab brains and guts and
stuff okay well when you put it like
that they have that on the menu - there
was a squid Stallman you're saying
it's gone I love rock sing it like that
uh-oh that's like the the best part
that's the doodoo all right I'm gonna
eat it I love it ginger quick just like
an apartment that's exactly what it's
green yeah dude Japanese guacamole
I'm bomb so another item I really want
to try it I think we're gonna add to the
list of things we Guinea is boiled God
milk and what that is there's a word I
probably won't today because this guy's
here but it's the reproductive fluid of
fish it's delicious I just tried it I
dip it in the sauce yeah the sauce is
ponzu
Oh mom right it's like hot Moony it's
actually not as flavorful of doing 20th
has more flavor
best flavor the routine but it's
hologram and I'm not even trying to make
fun but it's like a good all right here
is fatty tuna Toro
look I just more stuff look at that
any more aggresively guys
that's an authentic
this is my place look at that this is
one of my lifelong dreams was the Easter
shake in Japan I think I think anyone
that likes sushi their lifelong dream
should be the actual sushi in Japan in
that day we're all knock this off our
buckets right now orders
and I'm running a train
where we at what I'm here to do so what
just happened
cuz this girl that's what everyone's
making a comment about how softer
sweaters I don't know where he just goes
reaches out and touches her sweater and
I'm scolding him I'm like you can't just
touch random people touch you ain't
touch her I touched her sweater kids on
her you can't legislate
but you look part of it you can't touch
touch touch this letter it's on a person
you can't do that bo is your life you
behind it all that is hole saw and I
touched it no Jake
what is this leaving people go for it
robots for for the chicks you know who
got deal is a monster tape
back there right there looks [ __ ]
crazy it's just look it's just a mind
[ __ ] of how how much there is the
process holy crap I said I love these
toys look at piccolo all these different
kinds of ultraman's or some sort I grew
up on altra man
this was my [ __ ] back when I was a kid
Isaac Wonderland alright it's a better
time we have a tour guide taking us
around Tokyo we're going to do
restaurants and in reserve bus stop one
is fried food forget a preset meal I'm
with a lot of fried foods are you liking
the fried foods I'm not a really big
fried foods kind of guy so I mean it's
crunchy I like it but uh I'm also got my
food onto all right we just finished our
first stop on the tour on the izakaya
tour and I'm three beers in you're a
beer and beer and ass yes a mixed drink
in a keg Jeana Keough and I we all
thought oh the bad guys that guy looks
like you like five drinks anyways you're
going to our stop number two
and spot number two three more beers
here
not even three more beers - how many
beers are you in iPod - only two oh you
gotta catch up man all right number four
what is this tacky
you got your seafood place on top then
it's kind of like this egg flour batter
has cabbage and look at your doodles in
here all right just finished number two
location and we're going to get dessert
now and uh and I'm pretty gone I'm 35
you tried Sofia JPEG
we are now getting the dirt iris over up
and yeah we're in the middle of the
train station Boulevard get an ice-cream
eating ice cream
what kind watch all right so there's
matcha which is green peas there's
vanilla and there's a mix of vanilla and
greasy as where we go I got to yeah do
you like eating ice cream in the
summertime or the winter time I'd rather
have it in the summer but I know that
there are a lot of people really like
ice cream during the winter I had a
friend that worked at cold stone and he
told me that during the winter time it
would be even busier than the summer
time which took me out
that looks yummy it's delicious it's
very creamy that's it
it's the perfect balance of cream flavor
and green tea is there a lot of fun to
play for that's quite a bit how's the
ice cream bomb diggity it's pretty good
Cheers nice
she's in either though